une polémique alors que l'union
européenne vient de donner son feu vert
à l'utilisation du vaccin
kaiser bio ntech c'est donc nouvelle
phase qui s'ouvre dans la lutte contre
le virus
mais elle est loin d'offrir on l'aura
compris la nouvelle liberté de nouvelles
libertés aux français ou à certains
professionnels pour en parler nous
sommes avec alexis poulain c'est notre
rubrique l'édito bonsoir alexis poulain
un projet de loi qu'on peut qualifier de
surprenant oui au moins le timing est
surprenant une procédure accélérée
la veille des fêtes en catimini
quasiment pour éviter le débat
parlementaire
hier jean castex a présenté donc en
conseil des ministres ce projet de loi
pour la gestion de crise sanitaire
l'idée c'est de pérenniser à l'état
d'urgence sanitaire dans le droit commun
avec l'accès à certains lieux en
fonction d'un dépistage ou d'un vaccin
le déroger au secret médical avec des
fichiers personnalisé également un état
d'urgence sanitaire qui devait être
temporaire et qui rentre dans la loi
c'est inquiétant parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'on rentre dans la loi on perd en
liberté on n'est pas sûr de les
retrouver et donc cet état d'urgence
sanitaire
il arriverait par décret sans débat
parlementaire seulement un mois après
pour que le parlement puisse se réunir
et il donnerait un certain nombre de
pouvoirs au gouvernement notamment le
ministre de la santé 1 pourrait décider
d'imposer des mises en quarantaine donc
là c'est encadré ces mises en
quarantaine le premier ministre qui
pourrait bloquer les prix et aussi
procédé à des réquisitions de personnes
ou de biens et c'est pouvoir qui sont
données au gouvernement pourrait être
déléguées également préfet et puis cette
mise à l'isolément obligatoire si il en
mai pour des raisons sanitaires
elle pourrait être de plus 14 jours avec
l'aval d'un juge mais sinon ce serait le
fait de deux du gouvernement
alors pour le conseil d'état certaines
de ces décisions sont susceptibles
d'avoir des effets significatifs sur
l'exercice des droits et des libertés
constitutionnelles mais le conseil
d'état pense que ça va dans le bon sens
puisqu'il s'agit d'encadrer ce fameux
état d'urgence sanitaire alors alexis ce
qui fait à paul m
évidemment depuis 24 heures dans ce
projet doit qu'à sexe et l'idée de
rendre le vaccin obligatoire pour
certaines activités
oui alors ce n'est pas dit comme ça tout
ça est bien enrobé dans un texte de loi
qui fait référence à plusieurs articles
l'idée est effectivement de d'empêcher
les transports en commun certains lieux
l'accès à certaines activités ou des
lieux si on n'a pas fait de dépistage ou
si on n'a pas été vaccinés alors se
défend on dit que c'est pas le sujet de
ce qu vie de 19 ans mais d'une prochaine
potentielle crise sanitaire
néanmoins il est dans les têtes de tous
de cette idée du passeport vaccinale du
passeport vert porté par une député de
l'udi c'est un peu dans toutes les têtes
donc d'un côté voilà ce qu'on dit et de
l'autre voilà ce qui est dans les textes
à vaal inverse de ce que disait emmanuel
m'accrocher pas si vous en souvenez lors
de ses différentes allocutions
pour lui le vaccin devrait être nine
obligatoires alors on a fait nous en
tout cas nos petites recherches
s'étaient près-midi évidemment à l'écrit
poulain on a effectivement égoutter les
dernières prises de parole du président
macron qui s'est prononcé contre la
vaccination obligatoire d'abord le 24
novembre au cours d'une intervention
depuis l'elysée écouter la vaccination
doit se faire de manière claire
transparente en partageant à chaque
étape
toutes les informations ce que nous
savons comme ceux que nous ne savons pas
et je veux aussi être clair je ne
rendrai pas la vaccination obligatoire
et puis donc le 4 décembre lors de son
long entretien avec le média brut
écoutez je crois pas à la vaccination
obligatoire pour ce vaccin parce que
d'abord il faut être toujours très
honnêtes et transparents on ne sait pas
tout sur ce vaccin comme on ne sait pas
tout sur le virus après je crois
beaucoup plus au travail de conviction
par la transparence cas l'obligation une
érection alexis c'est quand même
étonnant c'est en même temps d'un côté
un président qui dit que ce n'est pas
obligatoire et de l'autre côté quand
même une stratégie d'al sorte de
passeport vaccinale porté par le premier
ministre et j'ai du mal à voir comment
ce projet de loi s'il était
constitutionnelle serait compatible avec
les annonces de l'irrévérence par
exemple sur le consentement vaccinale
tout ça serait contraire à la loi donc
reste à voir ce qui va se passer on peut
se poser des questions vraiment sur la
parole présidentielle en l'occurrence
alors justement la parole le président
macro un la prends beaucoup comment
interpréter cette interview au fleuve
d'emmanuel macron dans l'express pour
faire peut-être passer la pilule passer
la pilule ou la piqûre
je ne sais pas l'idée était un peu pour
lui je pense de parler à tous les
français il est déjà dans une stratégie
électorale avec ceux en même temps
partout présent dans cette interview
fleuve
il parle d'un peuple de paradoxe c'est
lui qui est assez paradoxal puisque lui
en parlant de névrose vis-à-vis du
rapport qu'ont les français à l'état en
disant qu'ils l'aiment et qui le
haïssent
on peut lui dire aussi qu'il a un peu ce
rapport avec le peuple français parfois
et puis cette emphase 1 il parle de
comment allons-nous métaboliser cette
crise que nous vivons il parle de
l'intimé beaucoup de choses profondes se
passe des choses intimes morale
psychique à l'échelle individuelle comme
à l'échelle du peuple il fait un lien
entre lui le peuple ce que nous vivons
tous
l'idée c'est un peu de brouiller les
pistes de dire que oui ce virus nous
touche dans l'ain team puisque c'est la
santé c'est ce que nous avons plus
proches et ça lui permet il vient
d'éviter de faire un état des lieux de
sa mauvaise gestion de faire aussi
croire qu'il a agi contre l'est des
côtes de localisation à l'époque mais
les accélérer avec alstom par exemple et
puis de dire qu'il ya un problème pour
lui majeure c'est l'écrasement des
hiérarchies le fait qu'il n'y a plus
d'autorité
parce que finalement le commentaire
permanent le nivellement complet créer
une crise de l'autorité mais pour moi le
problème ce n'est pas la crise de
l'autorité c'est la perte de confiance
finalement dans les autorités jean paul
sartre le disert la confiance se gagne
en gouttes
elle se perd en litres ces derniers mois
la confiance elle s'est perdue en
hectolitres pour qu'on voit la gestion
de cette crise même si lui pense qu'elle
a été formidablement gérer il ya un
rapport qui date d'octobre
intermédiaires qui parle d'un manque
d'anticipation de défaut de gestion
assez grave et lui alors là on touche le
le sommet de la dissonance cognitive
dans cette interview puisqu'à un moment
emmanuel macron dit que pour répondre à
la défiance il faut me semble-t-il
pour ce qui concerne les responsables
mais les l'action la cohérence et
l'explication
voilà en tout cas la ligne que je me
fixe or quand on regarde emmanuel macron
tous ces mois derniers
c'était à peu près tout sauf cette ligne
là qu'il s'est fixé il donnait comme
ordre français d'aller au théâtre avant
de confiner il disait que les masses ne
servait à rien mais finalement ça s'est
enfin son gouvernement
et puis c'est toujours le flou
l'incohérence qui ressort de ces
différentes mesures donc c'est de la
communication à classique
l'idée c'est de brouiller les pistes
c'est de dire que c'est la défiance qui
affaiblit la démocratie mais non pas le
manque d'action de la part des
responsables ou les mensonges de la part
des responsables
en parlant bien sûr de complotisme de
scepticisme sans jamais nommer les
oppositions et puis toujours cette idée
que c'est l'europe qui va nous sauver en
disant que le doute existentiel nous
l'avons dépassé grâce au rêve européen
ce rêve européen qui est en train de
couper la grande bretagne du continent
avec le break site qui est compliqué qui
a fait une réponse sanitaire désordonnée
qui comptera un crime d'être massive
alors en conclusion je dirais que pour
comprendre finalement emmanuel macron et
son action il ne faut pas écouter ses
discours ou lire sa pensée confuse
plutôt que complexe mais regardez ses
actes parce que eux ils parlent d'eux
mêmes merci alexis paulin